بالنظر إلى العوالم العديدة التي كانت عدة أجيال ، نحتاج إلى أن نكون دقيقين بشأن روح Hye.
انت فعلت
معبد العرافة ، براعم التنين القديم ، الرفيق ، عربة الخلاص
أيها الرفيق القائد الخاطئ الذي أعيدت وظيفته وزرع الحاصلات ،
تم نقل جميع السكان الذين أوقفوا سياراتهم اليوم إلى منطقة آمنة مسبقًا.
ما الذي يؤمن الناس بهذه السرعة ويسكنهم بسرعة
كما سيطر الفرع على الكنيسة بالتفصيل ،
الرفيق لاستخدام الديك والتغذية اللازمة للترميم
رأى Unpop قرية المزرعة ، التي تعرضت لأضرار في المبنى بسبب تأثير التصميم في المركز
الرفيق سينغو ، الذي يستعد لمشروع البناء ، لم يسبق له مثيل
قال إنه قرر تعبئة الجيش.
حيث يوجد 10 الآن هذه البيضة هي خطيئة والرفيق القائد يقوم ببناء الضرر للتعافي
إن موسيقى إيول البوب ​​، الضرورية للأعمال ، هي خطأ في المنطقة حيث يقوم الرئيس بتفجير الدهون المادية.
حوالي 130 المال و 600 حقل أرز ، أطلقت الحكومة
في 100 يوم ، حدث الكثير ، مثل انهيار المنزل التاسع.